[Musique]
1859 charles darwin y avait écrit dans
son livre l'origine des espèces
la sélection naturelle et recherche
partout et tout le temps
les plus légers à roter ration elle va
épouser celle qui sont nuisibles et va
accumuler selick sont utiles en ce
moment d'art oui il a défini les
processeurs des charges développement
les plus importants de notre planète
près de 4 milliards d'années des charges
développement ont permis l'existence de
la vie comme nous la connaissons
aujourd'hui
c'est assez incroyable ça peut être
assez vertigineux comme chiffres donc
pour donner un peu faire une comparaison
à ces chiffres
disons que ça va c'est équivalent à une
demi journée à 12h bas cela voudra dire
que les végétaux terrestres ils sont
apparus dans la planète depuis une heure
quarante-cinq les dinosaures depuis 35
minutes et nous les êtres humains depuis
deux secondes
donc c'est prescrit dans tout ce temps a
depuis décembre le mans les cliques se
sont complexifiées il ya eu donc
plusieurs innovations qui ont été
développés à cause de l'évolution comme
darvin à 10,6 et si ces innovations elle
était adaptée à la planète d'acteurs
contexte elles ont été elles ont été
sélectionnées laisse jusqu'aujourd'hui
celle qui n'était pas du tout adaptée au
contexte elles ont disparu en exemple
c'est intéressant d'un processus naturel
une ovation de la nature c'est la
photosynthèse je pense que tout le monde
si la connaît plus ou moins bien on
parle de ça depuis l'école primaire
par contre c'est un processus assez
complexe mais aujourd'hui on comprend
pas très bien tout ce qui se passe là
dedans mais en gros il ya de la lumière
est captée par les végétaux et par les
algues c'est là ça déclenche une
réaction chimique chefs des factions
chimiques et ça va produire de l'énergie
disponible pour les végétaux en écologie
fait le matin c'est dans un batteur
d'écologie on appelle ça la production
primaire
ça veut dire que c'est la stabilité
l'élément de stabilité des bases tous
les écosystèmes sans la photosynthèse il
n'existe pas des vies et y compris la
nôtre donc c'est assez surprenant
commune ouvre innovation qui a été
développé au fur et à mesure de la
sélection naturelle
par contre nous les êtres humains une
fois qu'on avait besoin d'énergie on a
dit bon c'est pas faire leur
photosynthèse
donc on a trouvé notre énergie on a
parlé chercher d'autres sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui on peut bien dire
qu'on s'a exploiter l'énergie solaire
ont utilisé tous que c'est la production
d'énergie photovoltaïque
par contre on fait pas du tout de la
même façon je sais pas si vous
connaissez
comment ça se fait un panneau
photovoltaïque y a des produits enfin
les cours des produits chimiques qui
sont assez dangereux et ça a quand même
un bilan carbone qui est assez
conséquent
rapidement on peut se poser la question
donc pourquoi on fait pas comme la
photosynthèse pourquoi on n'utilise pas
l'énergie solaire doit même façon ces
végétaux ou utilisent depuis des années
et des années
mais voilà aujourd'hui partout dans le
monde il ya des chercheurs qu'ils
investissent à fond dans cette question
comment détailler ses processus de la
photosynthèse pour produire les panneaux
photovoltaïques d'origine de la
prochaine génération
donc c'est sa bosse et vont être des
panneaux photovoltaïques bio inspirée
panneaux pour votre auto auront un
impact environnemental très faible voire
notre s'inspirer du vivant pour innover
durablement
c'est là on l'appelle le biomimétisme
donc on va chercher dans les vivants des
stratégies qui ont été sélectionnés au
fure décès d'amy journée d'évolution et
qui marche bien dans le contexte de
notre planète pour les utiliser pour
faire face à nos défis c'est pas dans
n'importe qu'elle défile on utilise ça
aujourd'hui beaucoup beaucoup avec les
focus avec l'accent pour faire face la
transition écologique donc pour donner
des pistes pour trouver des innovations
pour faire face à cette question qui se
pose aujourd'hui tout le temps peut-être
que vous me direz que c'est assez pas de
nouveau et ça je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est pas nouveau il ya eu des génies
parmi nous pendant deux secondes
d'existence qui ont cherché dans la
nature des solutions bien évidemment
leonardo davinci des premiers cas et
garder les vivants avec d'autres et avec
un autre égard et l'a fait ses premiers
bouche des machines volantes ans pilier
des oiseaux et les chauves souris mais
après dans les années 40 on a une
innovation aussi qui a été inspiré de
et c'est les velcros sais pas si vous le
savez mais les velcros il a inspiré de
cette petite fleur glace la sphère de la
barre des 7 fleurs à la une stratégie
d'accrochages qu'elle c'est assez
surprenant mais elle va s'accrocher dans
les pédales et aussi dans nos pantalons
qu'on avait on va faire une balade en
forêt pour se déplacer entre les
écosystèmes et donc continuer à exister
et voilà donc c'est les vivants qui
revient pour nous donner des sources
d'inspiration par contre dans les
parcours de notre existence dans les
deux secondes qui nous sommes sur cette
planète
on a innové on a créé pas mal des choses
aussi hein c'est pas mal c'est qu'on a
fait par contre on n'a pas de tous suivi
les mêmes règles du vivant on s'est
éloigné de cette logique des grandes
cycle de la planète et on a créé des
choses qui sont assez merveilleuse par
contre elles ont un impact
environnemental c'est important aussi
aujourd'hui nos innovations et les
schémas qu'on a choisi pour innover il
met en question toute la biodiversité il
met en risque tout les bio diversité et
toute l'existence de la vie sur la
planète qu'on la connaissons donc le
biomimétisme millet vient comme une
piste de réflexion briques de réflexion
et nous donne des pistes pour trouver
ces solutions dans les vivants pour
innover durablement en 2010 quand
j'étais ici ah ouais ça fait quelques
années c'est la même personne j'ai
changé quand même eu volage travail si
j'ai pensé un moment je ne savais pas du
tout qu'est ce que c'était
le biomimétisme par contre j'étais déjà
passionné des processus du vivant puis
ce qui s'est passé dans la nature et je
faisais cherche au brésil sur les
processus de traitement des eaux usées
par des processus biologiques un gros on
disait on prend pas loin qu'on n'arrive
pas de toi traités ont donné à manger de
bactéries ces bactéries celles qui vont
surveiller sur vire ils s'épaulent loin
peut-être elles vont arriver à
décomposer sales manager ça et continuer
à exister
c'était dans ces moments là enfin ça
c'est un gros c les processus qui a dès
hier la plupart des stations d'épuration
des eaux aujourd'hui c'était dans ces
moments là que je me suis rendu compte
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui la société
humaine elle est tellement dépendants
des processus naturels mais on se rend
pas compte mais on a tellement
dépendants et c'est surtout de ses
processus invisibles à nos yeux
qui se rend pas compte de tout qui sont
ma tout le temps pour aller dans les
concret vous de parler de quelques
exemples d'innovations biomimétique qui
ont été développées et que nous aident
donc pour faire face à la transition
écologique
je vais vous montrer quelques exemples
dont plusieurs échelles plusieurs
domaines on a parlé du velcro donc je
vous propose de continuer dans les
sujets de l'accrochage
je veux parler d'école la plupart des
cols aujourd'hui disponible dans les
marchés elles sont produit aussi avec
des produits chimiques dangereux
normalement elles ont des performances
moyennes
normalement les colts sont disponibles
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui ils n'arrivent
pas bien tenir en contact avec l'eau par
contre là on a une espèce kessé les
champions de l'accrochage il a un
processus physiques un processus
chimique pour s'accrocher dans les murs
je pense quelques-uns parmi vous ont
déjà essayé d'enlever un but hier dans
mur et on les vit en bus d'humour et pas
du tout les lierres vas voir c'est ça
aujourd'hui on est on avait des prêts à
beaucoup des charges sur les lierres
pour développer les super col des mains
et on à arriver à comprendre comment ces
processus des processus chimiques
fonctionne et on développe cette super
colle cette super quoi laisser un
produit biodégradable qui a une
performance beaucoup plus importante
tous les performances que l'on trouve
dans l'école d'aujourd'hui et ses
produits avec un processus de la chimie
verte
donc je trouve ça génial vraiment un
autre bâtiment pour passer cela c'est un
bâtiment mais on va passer à une autre
échelle d inspiration comment faire
aujourd'hui pour régler la température
de nos logements ont fait recours à deux
solutions les chauffage et la
climatisation
cessons de solutions qu'elles ont un
impact très important pour notre budget
à la fin du mois et aussi pour la
planète
par contre un peu évident qu'il ya des
espèces de la planète qui font fi comme
nous elles font face à des écarts de
températures assez important elles
doivent trouver des solutions pour
rigoler facilement ces écarts de me
faire actuellement
oui évidemment une espèce des
termitières est spécifique elle fait ça
trop bien ces bâtiments il a au zimbabwe
les architectes qui ont conçu ces
bâtiments
ils sont enfin ils ce sont des moins de
poser cette même question ils ont trouvé
cette termitière ces espèces de termites
ils ont pris plusieurs éléments ils se
sont inspirés de plusieurs éléments de
cette espèce pour concevoir ses
bâtiments ses bâtiments donc il va jouer
sur des éléments par exemple des
matériaux de construction mais aussi
d'infrastructures pour faciliter la
ventilation et l'échangé thermique les
chances d'humidité avec l'intérieur du
bâtiment l extérieur finalement il a un
confort thermique assez performant et il
consomme 35 % moins d'énergie que tous
les bâtiments de la même ville donc
c'est assez quand même chercher dans les
vivants a donné des résultats assez bien
pour ses projets mais il ya une autre
échelle que je trouve la plus fascinante
c'est l'échelle des systèmes écologiques
des écosystèmes pour parler de ça je
vais parler de la production de la
nourriture
imaginons une forêt cette forêt est là
des arbres des plusieurs gtalk ceux qui
vivent ensemble des animaux des insectes
bactéries des champions ils cohabitent
il vivait un équilibre et à plusieurs
relations qui se sont mises en place
là-bas et voilà donc
imaginons ses bananes et là il va
vouloir produire une banale il va
prendre les nutriments qui ont été
sifflés sont disponibles dans les soeurs
il va prendre des mots qui est
disponible sur place
il va prendre l'énergie solaire fait
refaire et court à la photosynthèse
qu'on a parlé au des boues début et
produire une baleine
cette peine va servir de nourriture
singer et voilà les sikhs les combats
continuent et donc un écosystème des
flux de matières des plus d'énergie des
fins d'information
comment ça se passe chez l'homme c'est
pas du tout la même chose
j'ai pu travailler dans un projet de
planification urbaine dans une ville que
c'était très spécialisé dans la
production de bananes de bananier
partout donc imaginé une colline à un
fleuve quelques kilomètres plus loin du
sommet de la colline jusqu'au bord du
fleuve on allait vite tous les arbres
qu'il existe on enlève tous les animaux
qui existent on plante des kilomètres et
kilomètres des bananiers
je pense que le reste vous le savez on a
simplifié les systèmes cette production
des baleines il va pas elle n'est pas
une autorégulation donc va falloir
ajouter des fertilisants de pesticides
et les ligues et pour produire des
bananes ça n'impacte un mental énorme
par contre cela n'a pas besoin d'être
toujours comme ça aujourd'hui les
concepts de l'agroforesterie de la
permaculture
ils nous proposent une production
d'énergie
sur qui va avec mais fonctionnement de
ces écosystèmes
on va produire dans de la nourriture
tout en respectant la biodiversité qui
existe dans une forêt donc on va sortir
de la logique de la mouture
aujourd'hui les études sur le ferme à
grupo et sierre il indique avec les
bonnes techniques un bon suivi de ces
plantations
on peut avoir une production nette
supérieure qui est dans une monoculture
dépenser moins d'argent et avoir un
impact sur la nature et se voit dans les
écosystèmes beaucoup plus faible c'est
pourquoi on fais pas ci fais pas ça
encore va je vous proposais garder cette
maj pour ouvrir un peu un peu notre
esprit sur la source en domaine
d'application du mimétisme qui ce
domaine qui me passionne les plus donc
j'ai travaillé un peu dans la biologie
après j'ai émigré pour la planification
urbaine donc c'était assez naturel pour
moi pour unir les deux points et
travailler avec l'application du
biomimétisme en planification urbaine
architecture donc là c'est une indécence
par luc 8 et ils nous proposent ils
envisagent comment ça pourrait être une
ville bien inspiré la cités végétales et
l'appellent les temps d'y arriver à ces
modèles de ville bio ans pilier on a eu
quand même quelques applications du même
métier dans une architecture qui change
un peu la façon de construire la ville
de demain
vous le savez la ville ces sont des
berceaux de la plupart d impact
environnemental aujourd'hui et sociale
aussi c'est quand même dans les
objectifs de développement durable de
débats onu donc c'est un champ fertile
pour le biomimétisme
ces bâtiments l'âge il tient beaucoup
mon coeur c'est un bâtiment assez
intéressant c'est un groupe scolaire en
ile-de france les architectes qu'on
aurait garé ne voit pas beaucoup qu'est
ce qui se passe là mais les architectes
ont conçu ces bâtiments
ils ont travaillé en lien étroit avec
des écologues pour essayer des répliques
et un écosystème d'une falaise donc dans
les murs tout autour de bâtiments ils
ont essayé désir bah on va pas faire un
mur qui c'est qui en mur pour isoler on
va laisser ses murs pour être colonisée
par les végétaux et les animaux
donc on s'inspirait des falaises ont
récréé plusieurs il se passait en
et petit hétérogénéité dans ce lourd
pour laisser à la végétation à iv
s'installer dans les bâtiments après les
bâtiments il a plusieurs autres léman
végétalisation des toitures des capteurs
d'utilisation des eaux de pluie et tout
ça que c'est des éléments qui se
rapproche d'un fonctionnement économique
mais pour moi c'est très intéressant de
chirurgie la logique de chasser la
nature et l'invité à habiter avec nous
construire la ville aussi pour la nature
équipe et paquet pour les êtres humains
à son tour ses bâtiments aux états unis
ils s'inscrivent dans une logique de
fonctionnement économique très
intéressant aussi donc à 20 qui s'est
bâtiment soit construit
ils ont fait un étude sur comment ces
écosystèmes fonctionne quel est le bilan
des eaux de pluie disponibles et quel
est le bilan d'énergie solaire
disponible sur place ils ont étudié ça
ils ont besoin de trouver ces chiffres
ils ont donné ces chiffres aux
architectes ils ont dit ok ça c'est la
limite de le bâtiment donc on peut pas
concevoir un bâtiment qui va dépasser
l'eau et l'énergie solaire est
disponible sur place et voir les
bâtiments
aussi il s'inspire il a beaucoup
d'éléments du bio inspiration et mis en
application du mimétisme
il a conçu une bonne partie en bois et
l'utilisent des lots ils s'inscrivent
dans un cycle de gestion de l'énergie
dont les quartiers c'est assez
intéressant les poufs à aimer ça change
la façon qu'on pense les bâtiments on
met les écosystèmes dans le coeur de la
conception aux rebelles de toute façon
je pourrais passer toute la soirée en
train de vous raconter des innovations
aurait été possible
une fois qu'on a compris les vivants
comme source d'inspiration qu'on a
regardé comment la nature fonctionne
pour faire face à des défis aujourd'hui
la transition économique écologique et
innover mais les plus importants qu'il
faut que vous riez tennessee la question
c'est les points c'est soyez curieux
une fois que vous faites vous vous
trouvez associés vous ne savez pas
comment innover comment trouver la
prochaine grande solution pour ce
problème
posez vous la question comment les
vivants a fait pour faire face à ces
mêmes défis c'est très probable qu'il a
déjà trouvé une solution qu'on peut
faire un rapport un transfert des
connaissances et finalement je vous dis
qu'est aujourd'hui si on veut changer le
monde et développer la société autrement
les liens entre y connecter les systèmes
mans avec les systèmes écologiques c'est
fondamental
on n'a pas d'autre solution finalement
on est tous nature aussi merci
[Applaudissements]